One of the concepts that comes up over
and over again.
Prolific creative minds that I've
interviewed for the Tim Ferriss show or
for the book tools of titans is creating
empty space.
And one of the guests,
Josh Waitzkin,
who never does any media,
can I curse on this?
Yeah.
He always texts me with profanity laden
SMS is because I'm the only one who can
pull them out of his cave,
uh,
to do media.
But he is best known perhaps as the
chess prodigy.
And I'll explain why I put that in air
quotes besides how funny it looks on
camera,
uh,
that form the basis or who formed the
basis for searching for Bobby Fischer,
both the book and the movie.
He was very well known chess player and
continues to be an incredible chess
player,
but he has applied his learning
framework to more than chess.
So he was a world champion and touchy
push hands is the first black belt in
Brazilian Jujitsu under the phenol and
probably the best of all time.
Marcelo Garcia who trains in New York
City,
I think he's a nine time world champion,
something like that.
And,
uh,
he's now tackling paddle surfing and he
can apply to just about anything.
He works with some of the top financial
minds in the world,
hedge fund managers and beyond the best
of the best,
top 1%.
So why?
What are the principles that he shares?
One of them is uh,
creating empty space,
cultivating empty space as a way of
life.
And these are all tied together so much.
And another one,
learning the macro from the micro and
then beginning with the end in mind.
And these all work together.
So I'll explain.
In fact,
the last two first Josh learned to play
chess,
or I should say more accurately,
was coached by his first real coach in
the opposite direction when compared to
most training and most chess books.
He was taught in reverse.
What does that mean?
He began with the end game and with very
few pieces.
So they cleared all the pieces off the
board instead of starting with openings.
Meaning what do you do first?
The first five to 10 moves,
start with the end game with king and
pawn versus king.
What does this do?
Well,
this forces you to focus on principles
like opposition creating space,
uh,
Zugzwang,
which is a principle of forcing your
opponent to do anything that will
destroy their position or anything they
can possibly do,
well worse in their position and these
types of principles that you learn when
there's an empty board with a few
pieces,
uh,
accomplish a few things.
Number one,
you are learning the macro,
the principles that you can apply
throughout the game of chess in almost
any scenario,
uh,
through the micro,
this,
this end game situation.
And these principles are adaptable.
You become a machine that can bob and
weave with the circumstances very
effectively compared to that as josh
would put,
put it if you're memorizing the
openings.
Okay.
And this might be like memorizing
recipes.
If you're learning to cook,
uh,
you're effectively stealing the answers
from the teacher's guidebook to a test
and you'll be able to beat your friends
for awhile and,
uh,
maybe even be considered a pretty decent
chess player.
But on a deep level,
you don't understand the game and you
will not,
you'll hit a ceiling and you will never
progress past that.
And you'll get beaten by really good
players so that can be applied to,
for instance,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
Josh told,
taught me basically all of the most
important principles of Jujitsu through
one move at the end game,
which is as a choke called the
guillotine,
which Marcelo was famous for.
His version is called the Marcello teen,
but it's effectively like this.
You're choking someone's head here and
he has a weird way of doing it where he
puts his forum on top of your shoulder.
It's pretty wicked.
If you want to be put unconscious,
you can go to that gym and,
and a experience that yourself,
but uh,
that can also be applied to many,
many other things.
For instance,
if you're trying to build a start up,
all right,
this is,
this is a common trendy thing to do
these days and I think everybody should
start a business at some point.
Uh,
but in the startup game in say Silicon
Valley where I live,
if you're going to go into the venture
backed world,
well you and your founder,
but I think a lot about the end game and
you should definitely have an agreement,
at least a working agreement,
a tentative agreement on what type of
exit,
say acquisition offer is acceptable to
you.
If those those end goal components
aren't in place,
then it's just a slow motion train wreck
waiting to happen.
And how might you do that?
Well,
if you're trying to learn the macro from
micro,
you could think about what the
acquisition agreement might look like.
So you could talk to lawyers,
get a sample template agreement and look
at the provisions,
look at the clauses,
and then reverse engineer it so that
when you're forming the company and when
you're hiring employees,
your decisions at that point make it
possible to have that contract at the
end.
This is another example,
micro,
maybe it's a 10 20 page document,
macro building,
a company that gets acquired by a much,
much larger company.
Uh,
so that is learning the macro from the
micro.
Uh,
another example,
just because I brought up cooking would
be saying,
choosing a recipe that involves two or
three primary techniques and perhaps
three to five primary ingredients that
apply in many,
many,
many different dishes.
So you're learning principles of safe
flavor,
combination principles of using
convection versus shallow frying or saw
Tang versus steaming.
Okay.
Uh,
that apply across the board.
And in doing so,
let's say you do without a recipe,
without a timer,
uh,
or I should say a meat thermometer or
something like that.
You're going to learn also to test the
food to know whether it has done or not.
That then applies to everything.
But you can do it just learning how to
make Harissa crab cakes with steam
Broccoli and I have no idea,
say candied yams,
something like that.
All right,
so that's that.
Now none.
We were also talking about the end game,
so we've covered that,
creating it.
We're cultivating empty spaces,
way of life.
This is very important to Josh Waitzkin,
who I mentioned.
It's very important to people like Paul
Graham who's the Co founder of y
combinator,
which is like the navy seals,
Harvard of startup accelerators,
keeping it simple,
let's,
let's just call it that for now.
Creating,
if you are a creator,
if you are a maker and not a manager,
this is important.
Creating three to five,
which by the way is a decision.
Uh,
so a lot of really good
entrepreneurs start as a technician or a
tactician.
They're very,
very good at one thing.
Then they end up in a managerial role
that they hate.
It doesn't mean you have to stay there
and you see a lot of folks like Evan
Williams and others who then at some
point realize this and return to a more
product focused,
uh,
role.
Even if they are also the CEO making
some high level 30,000 foot decisions.
Okay?
But if you are a maker,
if you've decided to be a maker,
if you just happen to be maker or a
creator,
let's call it three to five hour
uninterrupted blocks of time are
extremely critical.
If you want to connect the dots,
if you want to have the space to allow
yourself to have original ideas or at
least our original combinations of
ideas,
you really need to block out that time
and protect it at least once a week.
So in tools of titans,
there are many people who do this.
We meet Seti for instance.
There's a very,
very successful,
um,
multi,
multimillion dollar business that he
built out of a blog he started a long
ago in college,
which was very,
very niche.
And its focus,
he blocks out,
I believe it's every Wednesday for three
to five hours of time.
He will block it out for learning.
Uh,
Noah Kagan,
another entrepreneur does the same
thing.
So on Wednesdays for me,
I have from 9:00 AM to 1:00 PM.
This is pre lunch.
I have creation.
That means writing,
recording or some similar aspect of,
in my mind,
creating with,
with my skillset and my assets and a,
it is extremely important that I do that
before I'm barraged by inputs.
In other words,
and this is true of Josh as well.
First thing in the morning,
he's doing journaling.
Reid Hoffman,
billionaire go founder or founder of
Linkedin,
same story.
He will plant a seed in his mind the
night before a problem.
He wants to solve a project.
He wants to think about improving
perhaps and then waking up row,
Tabula Rasa,
complete blank slate immediately working
on that problem with journaling before
any text messages before any email,
which is why for instance,
I don't have email set up on my phone,
I do not have mail set up on my iphone
and I did not get notifications.
I also put my phone on airplane mode for
a lot of reasons for the four hour body,
explained some of the physical ones but
on to airplane mode when I go to bed and
it stays in airplane mode until I am
done with my creation period.
And then it comes on because as soon as
you go into bullet dodging or like
wonder woman bullet blocking mode with
uh,
everyone else's agenda for your time,
which is very often the inbox or text
messages,
you're Doa,
you'd done your creativity is,
is all for naught in general.
So for,
for me,
for many people who are say,
programming for musicians,
for creative types,
slack in the system,
you have to create slack.
You have to create space.
You have to create large,
uninterrupted blocks of time.
And the only way to do that is to put it
on your calendar.
If it's not on your calendar,
it's not real.
You need to put it in your calendar and
defend it just like you would anything
else.